Here's just a funny little media story.
It's becoming more and more popular in some
online circles.
To interject a nonsequitors about Jeffrey
Epstein didn't kill himself.
And the, uh, you're seeing this on Fox news.
You're seeing this online in the meme world.
I saw Joe Rogan tweeting some funny memes
related to it as well.
Uh, and Fox news was taking a cue from onald
Trump, uh, and doing a segment about military
dogs.
You might remember last week, Trump tweeted
about the dog that was apparently involved
in the suicide of ISIS leader, Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi.
And so total Fox clown, Jessie waters said,
Hey, let me do a segment about patriotic military
dog.
So we interviewed a former Navy seal who knows
about military dogs and the Navy seal blurts
out Epstein didn't kill himself when the segment
was winding down.
And it actually looks for a moment like esse
waters isn't even really paying attention
to the guests.
There seems to be a delay that's longer than
the satellite delay that they seem to be experiencing.
Here is warrior foundation, warrior dog foundation
founder Mike Ritland, taking a cue from the
Epstein, didn't kill himself memes and doing
it on live TV.
Who's to your left there and a, I'm sure he's
ready to go out on the next mission and he
can't wait.
So thank you and thank Nero for your service.
I appreciate it.
Absolutely.
If I could, cause I throw a PSA out real quick,
real quick.
Uh, just the, the remarkable nature of these
dogs and, and them being highlighted in the
news creates a huge demand by people that,
that frankly shouldn't have them.
If a, if you see the, the coverage and you
decide I want ne of these dogs, either buy
a finished trained, uh, you know, fully trained
and, and finished dog from a professional,
uh, or just just don't get ne at all.
Um, and Epstein didn't kill himself.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you for that commentary.
All right, Mike, maybe more on that later
and tonight.
This
is starting to get a cult following.
We dealt with some of the facts last week.
I don't feel that it's necessary to go back
into it.
It does not seem like this story is going
to go away anytime soon.
It's particularly popular with the Fox news
crowd, but I want to be really clear.
The Epstein's stuff is not just a right wing
conspiracy theory at this point by any means.
I'm in favor of inquiry.
I'm in favor of investigation.
I want to figure out what happened.
If we don't believe the official story, then
we should demand a transparency about what
took place.
But what I want to mention to you today, the
opportunity I want to take here is to remind
you that all of these right wingers who believe
that Epstein was killed, not that he died
by suicide, the right wingers are missing
the rest of the story.
They're not closing the circle.
onald Trump was accused of having raped a
hirteen year old girl at Jeffrey Epstein's
Manhattan apartment.
Trump is on video, which we've played for
you with Epstein evaluating the attractiveness
of young ladies in a very awkward looking,
uh, situation.
If you do believe that there was a plot to
have Jeffrey Epstein killed and to have it
ruled a suicide in order to prevent the trial
from going forward, but you don't believe
any of the disturbing and disgusting allegations
that involve onald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein,
then you're missing arguably the biggest part
of the story.
So I'm with you.
Inquire, investigate, seek the truth, look
at the autopsy reports, raise all the hell
you want, but don't pretend that if indeed
there was a plot to silence Jeffrey Epstein
before a trial, that it has nothing to do
with onald Trump potentially being incriminated
by that possible Epstein trial.
You're like ighty percent of the way there,
but you're ignoring the Trump piece, which
is allegedly and potentially a really major
piece in the entire Jeffrey Epstein fiasco.
So there it is.
Funny moment on Fox news.
We will see if this becomes a trend and more
and more people do it on a corporate media